I think not only can they live together
they have to live together because
without the two of them you're gonna
have some really severe problems in any
firm that's R&D intensive innovation
base whether however you want to put it
so I started the session this morning
with two claims and the first claim is
completely uncontroversial so we didn't
spend any more time on it which is
simply that innovation is required at a
pretty rapid rate these days and all
high-tech firms and many other firms the
second claim is more provocative which
is that most new ideas are bad and
that's actually empirically supported in
virtually every study of R&D or
innovation that I'm aware of so if you
look for example at the product design
firm IDEO
like down here in downtown Palo Alto
they come up with thousands literally
thousands of product design ideas every
year only if a handful I'm talking a few
doesn't make it to market and the
philosophy of that firm is that they
realize that most new product designs
are flawed
I mean bad is a strong word use it to be
provocative but most new product designs
are flawed in some serious way and as a
philosopher Karl Popper said a long time
ago about scientific theories the idea
behind scientist scientific methods of
testing is to kill off bad ideas before
they kill us off and so on the one hand
claimed one we need innovation claim to
most new ideas are actually bad so how
do you combine them because you've got
to combine them it's and the reason
you've got to combine them is because
entrepreneurs must in order to be
effective must worry about two kinds of
error not just
one kind of error you mentioned one the
that the the danger of criticism killing
off creativity points to type 1 errors
which is essentially not taking not
generating or not taking up good ideas
good new ideas which would be
breakthroughs or at least substantial
improvements either in products or
processes that firms are involved in so
that that's the one you know since we're
at Stanford University or right near
Silicon Valley and a lot of our students
are want to be entrepreneurs have been
entrepreneurs want to continue to be
entrepreneurs that's the one we tend to
focus on that's the one that's pointed
to by the eye the concern about
criticism killing off creativity but
they're also type 2 errors a type 2
error is the accepting of a bad idea and
this you know since entrepreneurship by
definition involves uncertainty and
innovation by definition involves
uncertainty you don't know I don't know
nobody knows whether that the idea
that's being kicked around the table is
actually going to turn out to be
fruitful to to create value we think it
will but we may not be very good judges
of it especially if we're the ones who
actually came up with the idea people
are notoriously badly calibrated I mean
everybody it's it's very tough to be
tough minded about your own idea so it's
easier for me to be tough minded about
your ideas and for you to be tough
minded about my ideas but my ideas my
own ideas are like my mental children I
have two real children whom I love and
nourish and cherish my mental ideas I
love a nourishment Church I have never
met anybody at the GSB or Stanford
University or any other elite University
I've ever been to that actually likes
their ideas being criticized
a couple of ideas came out of the
meeting this morning and one of them was
an interesting kind of routine that that
one of the firm's uses which is they
have a rubric which are simply a bunch
of criteria or dimension regarding
technical possibility regarding market
potential and so on and so forth that
any new idea has to be squirtle and as
the the entrepreneur who does this
explained to the rest of us in his firm
it seems that there's an understanding
that this isn't a personal matter so I
could have come up with an idea new idea
and it's promising on four of the six
dimensions but you know what I didn't
even think of dimensions five and six
and it turns out my design is deficient
on those this is just something that
happens to people when they're designing
new alternatives it's hard keeping a
large set of evaluation criteria my
Danna
and as he put it literally and I'm
quoting you know the designer in one
case just forgot dimensions four and six
and so and it turns out that the project
idea is not very good on those two
dimensions now let's suppose that it's
fixable on dimension four so it needs
elaboration which you're almost all new
ideas require needs elaboration it turns
out to be fixable
but on dimension six not so much well
you see at this point the process could
have been shifted away from the ego and
personality of the proposer and more
toward the nature of the problem itself
and when people's attention shifts to
the nature of the problem rather than to
the person then temperatures can cool
down
you can focus on what needs to be done
the good criticism will help the problem
solver figure out why they're stalled
and what they can do about it
a global criticism this is no good
doesn't actually provide directive
feedback of well okay so what is it that
I need to fix and do you have any
thoughts about how I might go about
fixing it now of course you know if I
come up with a really terrible idea in
that context if it's a really terrible
idea and the organization zones are a
lot of time pressure competitive
pressure it may be that frankly what you
just gotta do is pull the plug on that
idea on the project associated with it
and in that context good feedback is
fairly blunt traditionally leaders have
not tolerated being criticized what just
to take us back a little bit
historically what we might call the
Enlightenment project which goes back to
Europe and the 1700s what we could call
the Enlightenment project has to do with
the creation of a new authority system
in human institutions and the authority
system is not democracy it's not ruled
by the people but it's rather ruled by
evidence the appearance of the empirical
sciences in the seventeen hundreds and
taking off really in the 1800s has to do
with the creation and human organization
saying look you know it doesn't matter
how high up you are if you're making a
claim about the world this is going to
work this is not going to work it's an
empirical claim and you could be wrong
we're all fallible
that's the Enlightenment of ethnos we
are all fallible tell you a story I'm an
innovation story there was a doctor in
Vienna
the mid-1800s name Semmelweis several
vais worked in an obstetrics ward and an
important Viennese Hospital and he
didn't know anything about germs because
the germ theory of disease Pasteur and
Robert coffin Germany hadn't been
invented yet 20 years later it would
come so but some of us was worried about
pregnant women dying at terrible rates
in his in his ward and so he I don't
know how he stumbled on this empirical
method he stumbled on the idea of having
his people his doctors and residents and
interns wash her hands in chlorine
solution between patients and
importantly between doing autopsies and
patients may find it hard to believe but
in those days they would go from an
autopsy directly to the obstetrics ward
without washing their hands of course
their hands were just crawling with
bacteria they were killing women so some
of us had them wash hands and if you
look at an overtime plot of the death
rate in his ward it went like this
wash hand you didn't need econometrics
you didn't need statistics it was just
obvious from eyeballing the data
something about the chlorine solution
was saving women's lives well but you
know a lot of doctors in Indiana refused
to accept the evidence and they were
important doctors and positions of
authority and they didn't have to and
some of us died an embittered man it
wasn't until Pasteur and caution so
forth so we start to put the foundation
under this and you know then finally
those kinds of death rates started to go
away but the this is a long-term project
you put your finger on such an important
problem you can't expect it to be solved
overnight human beings are not
comfortable with the idea of saying the
boss at the top it's valuable to
everybody in the organization is
fallible everybody should be subject to
the authority of
but you know when we compare say medical
organizations we've got today our
high-tech firms we've got today
we've come a long way from the 1850s we
have made a lot of progress smart
leaders know how to create organizations
that protect themselves from themselves
you do things like you know we all eat
in the same cafeteria my office is not
on the 15th floor and is huge and grand
and everybody else now we do things to
minimize the status differences inside
the organization because it's those
status differences that are constantly
sending messages to people the CEO is
nearly a God he's infallible he's Steve
Jobs he can't make mistakes yeah he'll
everybody makes mistakes and when you're
a leader of an organization if you don't
create the kind of organization that
will correct your errors you could lead
your firm right over a cliff